all right so it begins now remember just
a few months ago during the midterms I
repeatedly warned you pretty much every
night about what the Democrats real but
hidden agenda was the agenda they were
hiding before the election they want to
impeach the president they want open
borders get rid of ice they want their
crumbs back desperately more regulations
and endless non-stop investigation into
all things Donald Trump and his
administration now every night as we go
over the news I want you to look at
things from a different perspective as
we talk to these new newsmakers on the
Democratic side ask yourself very
important questions because you're going
to come to a conclusion pretty quickly I
think are those in power that we show
you every night ask yourself is what
they are doing good for this country do
their comments do their remarks to their
actions do they strengthen the country
will what they're doing will it improve
the lives of the American people help
the American people advance our country
our country's interests now you can
forget about a red state blue state
Democrat Republican conservative liberal
left-right doesn't matter is what you're
seeing good for the United States of
America and the American people because
as we speak there are some in this
country so filled with anti-trump
rage every second every minute every
hour of every day
that they're willing to say and to do
anything to destroy the president his
family D legitimize the 2016 election
even if America and We the People suffer
as a result many months ago identified
what I call the five forces that are
actively working against the president
obviously it's Democrats they hate them
then you have of course the
establishment media they hate them never
Trump errs they want to be justified in
well not being a part of electing
somebody who has governed conservatively
establishment Republicans that are weak
and the deep state and for almost two
years they have been totally obsessed as
we all know by now Russia Russia Russia
with a few intermittent distractions
like storming
for me whatever else but on Friday those
five forces suffered a serious setback
when the special council's memos on Paul
Manafort Michael Cohen indicated no none
no evidence of any Trump Russia
collusion zero
it's about taxicab medallions loan
applications taxes in general nothing
about Russia or Trump now the destroy
Trump forces what kind of distraught so
they sent themselves into their typical
predictable convulsions then they
settled on plan B their back-up plan
imaginary campaign finance violations
against President Trump that's what the
Russia collusion was about and in their
sad and hate-filled world
Michael cones guilty plea to making the
illegal campaign contributions will
surely result in the end of President
Trump once and for all or so they say
let's take a look at this manufactured
but predictable hysteria this is a man
who came in and said I'm bigger than the
house I'm bigger than the intelligence
community I'm bigger than checks and
balances I'm bigger than the judicial
community I'm bigger than Free Press and
he's gonna pay for that the rest of his
life when immigrants procured their
citizenship by fraud we stripped them of
their citizenship when a president
procures his presidency by fraud should
we consider doing the same I think the
American people would support
impeachment Donald Trump will be must be
impeached he's got to know his future
looks like it's behind bars Donald Trump
is a criminal enterprise it certainly
looks like they are the kind of offenses
that would call for impeachment hearings
you have this memorable phrase of
individual number one you know it's
going to go down I think in the history
books along with some of those memorable
Watergate phrases he may be the first
president in quite some time to face the
real prospect of jail time when the
evidence becomes so clear that you very
likely have a criminal sitting in the
Oval Office
what is the Congress left to do at that
point the same people that have been
saying the same lies for two years and
it is unfounded
according to Fox News legal analyst our
friend Greg Jarrod if Michael calls
non-disclosure payment of stormy Daniels
or anybody else served a secondary
purpose
or dual purpose then it is not
considered a campaign contribution and
thus not illegal
in other words if the payment benefited
the Trump Organization the Trump brand
name even President Trump on a personal
or family level that's not against the
law it's as simple as that and the
president summed it up pretty perfectly
on Twitter writing quote there was no
collusion so now the Democrats go to a
simple private transaction Rolly call it
a campaign contribution which it was not
but even if it was it is only a civil
case like Obama's but it was done
correctly by a lawyer and there would
not even be a fine
lawyers liability if he made a mistake
not me Cohen just trying to get his
sentence reduced witch-hunt now remember
Cohn changed his story on this
particular issue and it's fascinating
because the liberal media and the
Democrats they only want to pick the
version that fits their desired
political goal
they didn't believe him the first time
even initially stated that the Daniels
payment for example came out of his own
pocket without the president's knowledge
and sadly most of his alleged crimes do
include lying and fraud but the media
wants to believe Cole now they don't
like Michael Cole they've never liked
Michael Kohn and they're not his friend
today and meanwhile the president has
acted in accordance with the law
committed no criminal campaign finance
violation and he sure as hell never
colluded with Russia which is what this
was supposed to be about but then we
have disgraced FBI director James Comey
'he's never let the presumption of
innocence get in the way of his complete
and total obsessive hatred for President
Trump last night he called on Americans
to oust President Trump with quote every
breath we have but he's not biased at
all take a look all of us should use
every breath we have to make sure that
the lying stops on January 20th oh I
guess he doesn't have a political agenda
the same guy that leaked information to
get Robert Muller appointed oh that's
the same Comey that might have espionage
issues himself by releasing those
documents and the same guy that well may
be in trouble himself with the law I
have some advice for Jim Comey don't
throw stone
from a glass house it's December but the
year of the boomerang is not quite over
now late last week Comey testified
behind closed doors on Capitol Hill
about the multitude of serious
controversies surrounding his leadership
at the FBI including FISA abuse his
handling of the Clinton investigation
and for a man who claims to have such
integrity such a great memory he seemed
to have a really hard time answering
questions or remembering anything that
mattered in fact many of those in the
room accused him of using his attorneys
to run an affair in swell another 245
times he says he can't remember one
shape manner or form the Republicans
came out and said the government lawyers
to the brand interference and shut down
specific lines of questioning did that
happen and if so what topics were not
discussed when you read the transcript
and I think you will not see that
happening and he did admit by the way
that the steel dossier was never
verified you know the bulk of the FISA
application we'll get to that in a
second so another lie from James Comey
now the transcript is out it was
happening over and over and over again
250 times according to trey Gowdy during
his testimony he answered I don't recall
71 times get this he stated I don't know
an additional hundred and sixty-six
times one lawmaker reportedly said quote
his memory was so bad I feared he might
not remember how to get out of the room
after the interview another claimed
quote it was like he suddenly developed
Alzheimer's after conveniently
remembering enough facts to sell his
book pretty awful a lot of selective
amnesia from someone who claims to be an
innocent man but even more troubling is
this is something called me actually
said during this hearing according to
this transcript from Friday he admitted
Hilary's bought and paid for dirty
Russian dossier the one that was used to
commit a fraud four separate occasions
on FISA courts was never verified either
before or after the FISA warrant
application let me explain this in other
words the FBI and the DOJ had zero idea
if what they were using to get one of
the
hardest warrants to get a FISA warrant
zero clue whether any of the evidence
was credible true and corroborated which
by law and by protocol must happen as a
matter of course they spied on an
American citizen trampled on his Fourth
Amendment constitutional rights a trump
campaign associate with information paid
for by the Clinton campaign and the DNC
that we now know is completely and
totally unverified but wait didn't rod
Rosen Stein or Sally Yates who signed
off Rada signed off on the final FISA
application didn't he say that law
enforcement if they're gonna sign a FISA
warrant didn't he say that that officer
must swear that the information and the
FISA request is true and accurate and if
he get it wrong there are serious
consequences
I know because well I have the tape
there's a lot of talk about FISA
applications and many people that I see
talking about it seem not to recognize
what a FISA a player application is
actually a warrant just like a search
warrant in order to get a FISA search
warrant you need an affidavit signed by
a career federal law enforcement officer
who swears that the information in the
affidavit is true and correct to the
best of his knowledge and belief and
that's the way we operate and if that's
wrong sometimes it is if you find out
there's anything incorrect in there that
person is gonna face consequences commis
gonna face consequences I'm just waiting
to find out what they are an American
was spied on by your federal government
think about this with a warrant based on
what was uncorroborated unverified
opposition research bought and paid for
Russian lies by Hillary Clinton and they
never told the judge that Hillary paid
for ever multiple judges were lied to
multiple frauds were committed on the
FISA Court when will we hear from the
FISA judges because those would be
crimes in all likelihood our own great
Jared has identified six specific
felonies that would be applicable on
this case alone
the left really cared about civil
liberties they would be demanding an
investigation they would care about
equal justice under the law equal
application of our laws and our
constitutional rights but like with
everything else to destroy Trump forces
they're willing to put all their hatred
for the president above everything else
for them it's always politics that
Trump's no pun intended
all it's the very reason they tried to
ruin justice Cavanaugh's life without
any due process without any presumption
of innocence on a case that had happened
36 years prior but at the same time that
barely yon said nothing over recent
abuse allegations physical emotional
against keith ellison their number two
at the DNC many of these same people
love Bill Clinton none of them spoke out
about Michael avenatti none of if you're
a Democrat you don't get the cabin or
treatment it's the very reason why they
obsess about Russia Russia for years but
they ignore the uranium one scandal or
if Vladimir Putin had a network inside
of this country the foundational
material of nuclear of nuclear weapons
for crying out loud
20% of America's foundational material
for nuclear weapons Putin's Network in
America we have a spy in there that's
chronicling bribery kickbacks money
laundering extortion and he's telling
the FBI oh then Robert Muller but the
deal still went through Hillary approved
it and guess what her foundation ended
up the people involved in that deal one
hundred and forty five million dollars
given to the Clinton Foundation and yeah
some of that uranium left the United
States where's the outrage over that
serious Russia scandal why would we ever
allow putin's thugs in america to get a
hold of our uranium and we don't even
have enough uranium as a country where's
that investigation and in the case of
Hillary's dirty dossier okay same year
2016 Russian influence her campaign
funneled millions of dollars o through a
law firm I bet if man afford or Michael
Kohn did it they'd be arrested but
anyway then using an out research firm
hiring a foreign national who uses
questionable spies from Russia
Christopher steel
puts together research from his sources
in Russia the dossiers based on Russian
lies paid for by Hillary literally
leaked to the American people to
influence the 2016 election I thought we
were investigating Russian influence in
the election no investigation into
bought and paid for lies to influence
the American people so you think about
this when you turn on these other
networks or pick up a newspaper you know
you think about this if you listen to
any Democrat across this country in
their sanctimony in their lectures talk
about campaign finance
there's no Trump Russia collusion but we
have major major mistakes let's see
Vladimir Putin tell tell Vladimir I'll
have more flexibility after the election
Dmitry Medvedev or the uranium one deal
or what we were just talking about and
that relates to the dossier